متجاورين يعني الحيط على الحيط سجن لالنا
للسياسيين بشتت
تنوع وانتماءاتهم يعني معتقلين
السجن الاخر هو سجن العسكر
العسكر اللي ارتكب جريمه
العسكريه اللي مثلا من الجيش او
بعقوبات مختلفه يعني او ارتكب اي جريمه
اخرى مثلا سرقه قتل
جريمه اخلاقيه كذا داخل الجيش بجيبوه
بحاكموا بجيبوه بيحطوه
جزء من المساجين العسكر لمسونيين بسجن
الثاني بيجيبون للخدمه هدول ايضا بعد فتره
من الفترات هذول
نتيجه الجو العام بيستشهرزوا هذا التوحش
العام
عدوى يعني سجنون ايضا يعاقبونهم او
يستخدمونهم
يعذبون ايضا هم طبعا يعذبوا هنا يعني من
عقر الفئات اللي موجوده
بالمعتقل
رغم شهاده امام السجناء الراي نتيجه انه
هن مثلا الحلاقين الشعر اللي كمان كان
يصير في تعذيب في خلال الحلاق بالضرب على
[موسيقى]
وطبعا كمان هون بنقول حسب تركيبته النفسيه
حسب تربيته حسب اخلاقه وحسب يعني الصلاه
كانت ممنوعه بالمطلق
واللي بيشوفوه عم بصلي يعني قد يكون
النهايه
يلجاون
هو قاعد بصلي
في سره يعني
بدون الحركات المعتاده يعني
المشنقه الى الاعدام يلصق لاصق على فمه
بالبدايه كان
صار بعض المسائل بمعنى انه السجين اللي
رايح يا عم صارت الحبل برافته
مؤمن بيكبر بيكبروا المساجين الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لجعوا سجاني عاد مجموعه من الاجراءات منها
تكميم السجين بلاصق بلاستر بحطوه وهو رايح